Anna is on a treasure hunt not far from
her home in southwestern Germany
[Music]
the treasure she seeks butterflies once
spotted she stalks them
[Music]
what's your favorite butterfly here many
things my favorite is the purple emperor
we saw one once and it was so amazingly
blue a really dark and shimmering blue
for the past five years the 16 year old
has documented the biodiversity in her
area it's hard to say if species are
disappearing or decreasing but she's
definitely noticed new ones 20 years ago
for example there weren't any marbled
fritillary butterflies here now I see
them all the time in the summer so it's
clear that climate change is having an
effect
butterfly watching has increased her
commitment to climate protection this
summer Ana is taking part in the two
degrees campus an environmental seminar
for young people run by the World
Wildlife Fund the program sends the
youngsters out to do field work in order
to learn how to combat climate change
the focus for Anna's team is nutrition
agriculture creates many greenhouse
gases at this organic farm they learn
firsthand about climate friendly farming
it's a hands-on approach to climate
protection protection is fun because it
gives me something in return I feel like
I'm doing something worthwhile with my
time I really enjoy it during their tour
of this farm the students learn about
what pigs eat for example and about crop
rotation the students record the
information for the group the
participants here are all interested in
climate protection but they know that
back at home some people are still
skeptical sometimes you have to debate
and discuss it with people a lot of
people I know are skeptical about
climate change that's gonna be a bit
difficult but no one really laughs at me
because I enjoy talking about it and
fast ya know the school the 2° campus is
seeking to raise awareness of climate
change this year's program continues
until October through the two degrees
program I've learned so much about our
consumption habits and the impact they
have on other countries and on us here
it's hard to cut down on consumption
especially when you're with other people
and they're all eating meat for example
but on the whole if you're motivated
it's easy to help protect the climate
back home my sister milena enjoys seeing
the butterflies anna has found we saw
this today do you know what kind it is
come in blue yes a common blue they're
the most widespread they're pretty anna
uploads her pictures to an online
database called art and fender it's a
place for people to document the flora
and fauna in the state of
rheinland-pfalz she's already uploaded
about 700 entries each discovery is
flagged on the map
Anna often heads out alone or sometimes
with her family once we were in a meadow
a wet meadow we were marching along
looking for a large copper and there it
was that's really great when you set out
looking for something and you find it
that was nice that's that showing up
soon Anna we'll have to cut down on her
butterfly expeditions at least during
the week when she's in school but on the
weekends she'll be out again treasure
hunting
[Music]